Bill Maher
Bill Maher says
that Barbie was terrible he said okay
Barbie I was hoping it wouldn't be
preachy man-hating in a zombie lie alas
it was all three what's a zombie lie
something that never was true but
certain people refused to stop saying it
uh tax cuts for the rich increase
revenues for example or something that
used to be true but no longer is but
certain people pretend it's still true
Barbie is kind of a zombie lie it goes
on this whole long essay he hated Barbie
I rest my case
you know I had a little bit of a debate
with arpel Ben Shapiro and some other
conservatives this Barbie really split
the conservative movement
and
now that Bill Maher says that Barbie was
terrible I rest my case
that it was terrific
there were some people pointing to Bill
Maher's commentary and saying see this
this proves that Barbie was bad
Bill Maher is wrong about pretty much
everything
but
I think I'm so glad Bill Maher disagrees
with me that's how I know I'm right and
and this ties into something we were
talking about a little bit earlier
which is a deeper issue here and that is
Bill Maher is a liberal he's a he's a
progressive liberal but he's styled
himself in recent years a slightly more
classical liberal I don't know classical
meaning he's a liberal from the 90s and
some conservatives some people on the
right have really gone along with this
some of the squishier people on the
right say oh I agree with Bill Maher on
all sorts of things
that's a problem
Bill Maher is
an atheist libertine who
maybe will say wokeness has gone too far
or something if that's the best
conservatives can do if the best
conservatives can do is conserve 90s
liberalism then let's just hang it up
folks if we cannot offer an alternative
political vision
if we're if the moment that someone does
offer an alternative political Vision we
just cut and run and go whine on MSNBC
and CNN then just hang it up then there
are no conservatives in America
if you can't recognize that Bill Maher
is wrong about the most important things
he's funny I like I like Bill Maher he
invited me on a show one time I didn't
make it uh maybe I'd be happy to go on
again I like him in some ways it's kind
of funny but he's wrong about everything
and if a conservative can't acknowledge
that you know
come on
then you probably don't even realize
that Barbie's a good movie right now go
to geniusell.com Knowles YT our friends
over at geniusell sold out of their Dark
Spot Corrector and our listeners have
been begging begging like dogs for a
restock well I've got great news just in
time for the summer it's back in stock
genyourself's famous Dark Spot Corrector
has not won but three cutting-edging
Radiance and goes to work fast to Target
sunspots dark spots liver spots even all
discoloration both on your face and
hands you can now enjoy your summer sun
Beach and barbecues without embarrassing
spots geniusell's most popular package
also features their summer Essentials
such as the best-selling Ultra retinol
moisturizer with a powerful retinol
alternative for safe use in the sun see
results very quickly or 100 of your
money back guaranteed go to
geniusell.comt right now to get your
dark spot corrector in the geniusell
most popular package that is genucel.com
knowlesyt right now save over 77 zero
percent off jnsl's most popular package
all orders include a mystery luxury gift
while supplies last geniusell.com
Knowles y t Jonah Goldberg
is typifying this he's Furious that that
people aren't just going along with the
program Jonah came out with a book after
he had his his big split with the GOP
and the conservatives over Trump he was
one of the true and Veteran never
trumpers he like a lot of the
self-styled classical liberals wrote one
of these books about how everything
today is really great and all those dumb
stupid people in the middle of the
country need to shut up and stop
complaining because you know the the
Enlightenment and Classical liberalism
is just so wonderful and we just we
don't appreciate it enough and so Jonah
Goldberg is following this idea now to
its logical conclusion by complaining
about the uh fact that people Ordinary
People
have a say in the nominating contests
for the GOP he's complaining that
candidates are paying attention not just
to the big Mega donors on Wall Street
but to the small dollar ordinary donors
in on Main Street they just also the
thing that we were dealing with a time
where there are a lot of people there
was a there's a lot of cheering and and
self-congratulation about the rise of
small donors a decade ago and now small
donors are actually one of the biggest
problems for democracy for the GOP
because small donor large donors
actually
I have a strategic view about moderation
who can win who can't small donors
really are just venting their spleen
with their credit card and um and they
lock candidates into positions that can
hurt them in the general election
venting their spleen
the contempt just dripping from his
voice they're just these small these
small dollar donors which is to say
Ordinary People these Ordinary People
they're a real threat to democracy
this is the exact same thing Hillary
Clinton said these deplorable
irredeemable Ordinary People they're a
threat to our democracy because
sometimes they want something that I an
elite liberal do not want
and that's a big threat
Jonah's actually taking the argument
even further you've got to give him
points for at least being honest about
his views here where he's saying you
know if these campaigns were just
decided by a handful of billionaires on
Wall Street we'd be so much better off
our democracy would be so much healthier
of course that's an incoherent statement
democracy is government of of the People
by the people for the people
but he's showing you
that when liberals on the left and on
the right when they use that term
democracy when they complain because the
Hungarian people elected Victor Orban oh
no this is a threat to democracy how
could the people voting for someone be a
threat to democracy what they mean by
democracy
is liberalism
of a very elite
theoretical ideology
that is have is having all sorts of
problems in practice
but to which these people cling with the
Zeal of the most Ardent converts and
proselytizers
of course of course but it's not
convincing people and so when that
argument doesn't convince people then
the Liberals on the left and the right
turn against the people explicitly ASA
Hutchinson's doing exactly the same
thing as Hutchinson who I theoretically
is running for president he's the former
Governor of Arkansas who who became best
known for insisting as a quote-unquote
republican Governor insisting that we
in Arkansas ASA Hutchinson made the same
point the fact is I'm not a self-funded
candidate uh and and the RNC rules is
burdensome on the candidates to instead
of focusing on other ways of raising
money and focusing on other styles of
campaigning I've got to spend all of my
time at the Iowa State Fair trying to
get on the debate stage with one dollar
contributions and so uh that's not
helpful and it's not good for our
Democratic process it's not helpful
to me that I can't just call a few
billionaires and then become the
president
I have to go I have to talk to those
disgusting filthy people in in Iowa
I got to go to the state fair and eat a
corn dog like a like a plebeian
can you imagine like a rough neck
disgusting peasant
and that's a big threat to I got to talk
to people
it's a big threat to our democracy if
I've got to talk to people to become
their president
notice where ASA Hutchinson made this
comment
did he say it on the daily wire did he
say did he say it on Tucker Carlson's
show
no you say it on the blaze did he say it
no
he didn't even say it on Fox News
he said it on MSNBC where did Jonah make
his comments I believe it was CNN
these these guys
were Republicans
even it pains me to see what's happened
to Jonah Goldberg because I used to
enjoy reading him sometimes
but
the moment that Donald Trump came in and
injected a little bit of nationalism a
little bit of populism into the national
conservative conversation all those guys
split
said nope no thanks I was willing to
play around with the Republicans for a
little bit when I thought that I could
steer the party in a liberal Direction
but now that I can okay I'm I'm
effectively a Democrat
I know Jonas I think still says he's a
republican as Hutchinson's running as a
republican for president doesn't have a
snowball's chance in hell but in their
practical lives where do they write who
funds them what TV channels do they go
on it's all
for the left the Liberty Russell Kirk
made this warning in the early days of
the post-war conservative movement when
there was the prospect of a fusion
between the conservatives and the
Libertarians Russell Kirk the great
conservative political philosopher
warranty said this is not going to work
out very well because a lot of those
Libertarians ultimately are gonna gonna
move to the left
what a great clip now now
you gotta ring that Bell subscribe to
the Michael Knowles Channel we'll see
you next time